دوت صافرات الانذار صباح الاثنين في
الجولان السوري المحتل اثر سقوط قذائف من
الجانب السوري لليوم الثالث على التوالي
وياتي ذلك بعد قصف اسرائيلي على مواقع
للنظام السوري في القنيطره خلال اليومين
الماضيين ردا على قذائف انطلقت من معارك
بريف القنيطره بين الجيش السوري والمعارضه
المسلحه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ونناقش فيما وراءه ما هي الاسباب
التي قادت الى التصعيد الاخير بين اسرائيل
والنظام السوري في منطقه الجولان وما هي
الافاق المحتمله لهذا التصعيد في ضوء
التهديدات المتبادله بين الجانبين على
خلفيته
حسب متحدث عسكري اسرائيلي فان قاعده القوه
الدوليه شماليه هضبه الجولان السوريه
المحتله كانت صباح الاثنين هدفا لطلقات
رشاشه قادمه من الجانب الذي تسيطر عليه
سوريا من الهضبه حدث هذا في اطار تصعيد
دخل يومه الثالث وقصفت خلاله القوات
الاسرائيليه على مدى يومين مواقع لجيش
النظام السوري قالت انها كانت مصدرا لقض ف
سقطت على الجانب الذي تسيطر عليه من هضبه
الجولان التصعيد الذي جاء على خلفيه
مواجهات بين المعارضه السوريه المسلحه
وقوات النظام في المنطقه اثار الكثير من
الاسئله بشان دوافعه وحسابات دمشق وتل
ابيب وراءه تقرير ناصر ايه
الطاهر تلتهب القنيطره لكن مدى الرؤيه
فيها يتسع ذاك مفعول المعارك المحتدم في
الريف الاوسط للمحافظه الواقعه بجنوب
سوريا الغربي احد طرفيها غرفه عمليات جيش
محمد وهو مسمى وليد تنضوي تحت لوائه فصائل
معارضه مسلحه اما طرف القتال الاخر
فالنظام السوري مجرد واجهه له لان قاده
حربه ومنفذيها هنا ميليشيات طائفيه
اجنبيه تسعى المعارضه المسيطره على مجمل
اراضي القنيطره لضم كل من مدينه البعث
وبلده خان ارنبه الى قائمه
مكاسبها كسرت بالفعل اولى خطوط النظام
الدفاعيه بسطت سيطرتها على كثير من نقاط
تمركزه وقتلت عشرات من جنوده
وحلفائه مع ذلك تسمع من قوات النظام ما
يفيد بانها احبطت هجمات المعارضه وكبدتها
خسائر كبيره انها الحرب ولانها كذلك فلا
عاصمه للنيران من الانزلاق وحدث ان فعلت
الى داخل الجانب المحتل من هضبه الجولان
فهناك سقطت قذائف صاروخيه بارض فضاء وقيل
انها لم توقع اضرارا بشريه لكن بالنسبه
لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كان ذلك امرا
غير مقبول فقد قصف مرارا اهدافا تابعه
لقوات النظام السوري قال ان القذائف خرجت
منها ليست غارات اسرائيل الجويه ولا قصف
دباباتها المتمركزه في تل الندى باتجاه
القن
بامر جديد يحدث ذلك كلما اطلقت نيران
باتجاه الاراضي المحتله وكلما علم بقدوم
شحنات اسلحه او وجود قيادات لميليشيات
تؤازر الاسد قرب المناطق
الحدوديه والان تقدم قياده جيش النظام
تفسيرها الخاص للواقعه الاحدث فهي تصور
القصف الاسرائيليه لمواقعها العسكريه بانه
محاوله لدعم من تسميها المجموعات
الارهابيه صد بالطبع المعارضه السوريه
المسلحه التي تتشكل هنا بالاساس من فصائل
لم يجرع اي طرف اقليمي او دولي على وصمها
بالارهاب لا تعبا اسرائيل بتلك الاعتبارات
كثيرا فلها حساباتها الخاصه تقول حكومتها
انها سترد بقوه على اي قذائف تسقط فيما
تسميها ارض اسرائيل اذا كان مطلق القذائف
ايا كانوا قد اختبروا رده الفعل
الاسرائيليه فقد نالوها لكن ماذا بعد في
الظاهر تصر تل ابيب على القاء اللوم على
حكام دمشق غير ان رسائلها التي ردت بها
على القذائف الشارده بدت متجهه الى عنوان
اخر فهذه منذ مده ساحه نشاط ميليشيات غير
سوريه تدعم الاسد يتقدمها حزب الله
اللبناني يدرك الاسرائيليون ان هؤلاء
تدعمهم طهران وتمدهم باسلحه متطوره و ذا
كما تخشى تل ابيب من انه سينشئ وضعا جديدا
على مرمى حجر من الجولان
المحتل موضوع حلقتنا اليوم نناقشه مع
ضيفين من باريس الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي عبد الناصر العايد ومن القدس
المحلل السياسي يوني بن مناحيم لكن دعونا
بدايه مشاهدينا نكون مع مداخله من بيروت
حول نفس الموضوع مع الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي
توفيق شومان مرحبا بك سيد
توفيق في اي اطار يمكن ادراج هذا التصعيد
المتوالي جنوب هضبه الجولان السوريه سيد
توفيق تحيه اليك اولا سيد حسن جمول ثانيا
اعتقد بان الامر مرتبط بالمتغيرات
الميدانيه التي تحدث في مجمل الجنوب
السوري وفي الباديه
السوريه ايضا منذ اوائل السنه الجاريه هذه
بحسب على الاقل مركز ابحاث الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي ان الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه
الامنيه اتجاه الاوضاع السوريه يجب ان
تشهد تغييرا وهو منع ان يكون هناك وحده
امنيه متراصه بين جنوب لبنان وبين الجولان
بمعنى ان ان لا يكون هناك جبهه موحده
ممتده من الجنوب اللبناني الى الجولان
السوري والمرتفعات ال والمرتفعات السوريه
المحتله كيف ذلك وفي اي و وباي وسائل انا
اعتقد نعم لان لانه في في في الفتره
الاخيره على الاقل منذ سيطرت بعض الفصائل
السوريه المسلحه وبالتالي بقاء وحدات من
الجيش السوري في محافظات الجنوب السوري
وتحديدا في منطقه القنيطره حيث تم العمل
على انشاء نوع من المقاومه الشعبيه
السوريه للاحتلال الاسرائيلي ادرك
الاسرائيليون وهذا الامر على كل بح بحثه
بنيامين نتنياهو مع الروس اكثر من مره بان
تكون منطقه بان لا تكون منطقه الجنوب
السوري امتداد لما اسماه النفوذ الايراني
وطلب من الروس على اي حال ان تطلق اليد
الاسرائيليه ابتداء من اي من دمشق الى ال
الجنوب السوري هذه هذا المتغير المتغير
الامني ال الاسرائيلي اعتقد بانه اصبح
ربما اكثر سخونه في الفتره الماضيه من
خلال مجموعه من المعايير ومن الحقائق
والمعطيات الميدانيه التي تحققت على الارض
وبالتالي يخشى الاسرائيليون الان من ان اي
تقدم للجيش السوري وحلفائه في منطقه
القنيطره بالتحديد التي تعتبرها اسرائيل
طيب
جيد حلفاء الجيش السوري ماذا يعني ذلك
ماذا لو سيطر الجيش السوري وتقدم هل سنكون
او سنشهد هنا مواجهه عنيفه بين الجيش
السوري والقوات الاسرائيليه ام
ماذا انا اعتقد بان احد عناصر
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه الامني بالتحديد
في الجنوب السوري هو اطاله امد الحرب
وبالتالي منع تحديدا منع الجيش السوري
وحلفائه من تحقيق انجازات امنيه كبرى على
الجبهه الجنوبيه هذا ما يقوله مره ثانيه
اقول الجنرال عموس يادلين رئيس مركز ابحاث
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي واظن بانه على
الاقل بعض المقالات التي ظهرت في الايام
الاخيره وبالتحديد منذ مارس اذار الماضي
وايار الماضي ايضا مايو ايار مايو الماضي
تسب في هذا الاتجاه منع تحقيق انجاز كبير
للجيش السوري وفاء الجيش السوري لان هذا
الامر يعتبر يعتبر نفوز لما يسميه
الاسرائيليون الاذرع الايرانيه ط سؤال
اخير هنا من من وجهه نظرك يعني اذا لم
تنجح اسرائيل في اطاله امد الحرب واذا اصر
الجيش السوري و حلفائه ومن ورائهم ايران
ان يخترقوا تلك الخطوط خطوط المعارضه
والتقدم اكثر
باتجاه جبهه جنوب
الجولان كيف تتوقع ان يكون الرد او هل
ايران في وارد الان هي وحلفاؤها الوصول
الى تلك
النقطه انا اعتقد بان جزءا من الخطه
الميدانيه السوريه هو استعاده كافه
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه
السوريه وهذا يجري على قدم من وساق في
اكثر من منطقه ولكن الخطه البديله
الاسرائيليه وكما يقول الاسرائيليون
انفسهم هو انشاء حزام امني في المناطق
السوريه المحاذيه للاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله هذه هي الخطه التي يعمل عليها
الاسرائيليون وقد يعني وهي على كل موجوده
بالادراج وتم بحثها مع اكثر من طرف دولي
وسابقا قلت او قبل قليل تم بحث هذا الامر
اكثر من مره في الزيارات المتكرره التي
قام بها بن منين نتنياهو الى موسكو ولا
اظن بان الامريكيين ايضا بعون عن هذه
المساله اي تقدم الجيش السوري وحلفائه
الخطه البديله الاسرائيليه هي اقامه حزام
امني وهذا امر مطروح منذ اندلاع الازمه
السوريه في اذار مارس من العام 2011 اشكرك
جزيلا توفيق شومان الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
شاركتنا من بيروت في هذه المداخله اشكرك
جزيلا
اعود الان الى ضيفي من باريس الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي عبد الناصر العايد
ومن القدس المحلل السياسي يوني بن مناحيم
لو بدات معك سيد عبد الناصر العايد هل
توافق ما ذكره توفيق شومان من بيروت بشان
الاستراتيجيه التي يتبعها النظام وايضا
الرؤيه التي تنظر فيها اسرائيل لما يجري
في الجولان
يعني اولا اسمح لي بس عبر عن موقف مهم انه
المعارضه السوريه ولا اي والوطنيين
السوريين لا يمكن ان يروا في الضربات
الاسرائيليه لنظام الاسد يعني شيء في
صالحهم اسرائيل مغتصبه ومحتل لارض سوريا
ونظام الاسد مغتصب للسلطه وقاتل للشعب
السوري وكلاهما عدو للشعب السوري لا يمكن
يعني ان ان يدعون للابتهاج ان تضرب
اسرائيل نظام الاسد هم بينهما على كل حال
تحالف موضوعي منذ سنه 1967 منذ ان تم
تسليم الجولان لاسرائيل من قبل حافظ الاسد
للوصول الى السلطه فيما يخص الضربات
الاخيره يعني هي ليست ضربات جديده ولا هي
شيء يعني غريب اسرائيل الطائرات
الاسرائيليه تقصف متى شاءت في سوريا وتنقل
انتم باستمرار اخبار عن ضرب ضربات
اسرائيليه في عمق الاراضي السوريه
هذه الضربات الاخيره ربما تكون ميزتها انه
يمكن اقل وقعا يعني ليست ضربات كبيره هي
اشبه بصفعات صغيره لنظام الاسد بعتقد انه
هي بتجي كما ذكر ضيفكم من من بيروت بتجد
ضمن سياق بالفعل الصراع الايراني
الاسرائيلي وليس الصراع المباشر مع نظام
الاسد بمعنى انه اسرائيل لديها خطه
للهيمنه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وايران
لديها مشروع اصبح واض واضح المعالم هناك
تنافس بين هذين المشروعين اسرائيل تريد
لنظام الاسد ان يتنبه الى دوره الوظيفي
الذي لعبه طوال 40 سنه اكثر اكثر من من 40
سنه ماضيه بخدمه بقاء اسرائيل يعني عمليا
اي تريده ان لا ينجرف وينساق كليا الى
المشروع الايراني وهذه تنبيهات له لانه
بدا يعني بعض التحرك هناك تحركات في منطقه
يعني منطقه القنيطره لصالح اميات ايرانيه
حب الله وغيرها تمتد الى هناك دعني اسال
السيد يوني بن مناحيم من القدس لماذا تخشى
اسرائيل كل
اي هذه الحركه على حدود الجولان وهي التي
تقول بان القذائف التي تسقط انما هي
قذائف نتيجه المعارك وغير مقصوده فلماذا
كل هذا الرد وهذا العنف وهذه الخشيه التي
عبر عنها بنيامين من نتنياهو
اي لان في هناك رساله اسرائيليه ل لسوريا
ويران بان اسرائيل تريد الحفاظ على الامن
والاستقرار والهدوء في منطقه هدبه الجولان
واي اطلاق نار سيكون هناك رد اسرائيلي
عنيف لان اسرائيل تريد ان تحافظ على هذا
الهدوء واسرائيل تخشى من ان من ان ايران
تريد فتح جبهه جديده
في هدبه الجولان ضد دوله اسرائيل وكانت
هناك
محاولات لذلك من قبل سمير قنطار اذا تتذكر
وجهاد مغنيه وردت اسرائيل بقوه على هذه
المحاولات وهذا هو حت احمر فيما يتعلق
بسياده اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بالازمه في
سوريا يعني القصف الذي يحدث ليس ردا على
الق ذائف بقدر ما هي رسائل مبطنه ورسائل
ناريه للجانب الايراني قبل الجانب السوري
هذا ما
افهمه بالتاكيد هي
رساله لايران ورساله لسوريا اللي هي خليفه
ايران بان اسرائيل لن تسمح بفتح جبهه
جديده سوريه او ايرانيه في هدبه الجولان ا
طيب
سيد عبد الناصر الع سيد النظام السوري
يقول ان القصف الاخير انما جاء من اجل
تدعيم موقف المعارضه السوريه خصوصا وانه
جاء بعد تقدم احرزه الجيش السوري في منطقه
ريف
القنيطره يعني هذه اسطوانه مشروخه دائما
يتحدثون بها يعني كل يوم اسرائيل تضرب كما
قلت سابقا تضرب في عمق الاراضي السوريه
وفي عمق المواقع النظام و يعني تستهدف
اهداف اكثر خطوره واهميه من هذا الهدف اي
هذه يعني ذريعه واهيه دعم الجماعات وما
الى ذلك اسرائيل لا تخشى انا يعني اختلف
مع من يقول انه يعني اسرائيل تخشى تواجد
لجيش النظام او حتى للمليشيات الايرانيه
في هضبه الجولان انه يكون
مؤثر القوات الايرانيه وحزب الله والنظام
كله لم يستطع ان يتغلب على مجموعات من
القوات من قوات المعارضه يعني متفرقه
ومتشرد ولا تملك لا سلاح ثقيل ولا طيران
ولا دبابات فهل يستطيع يعني ان ان يهاجم
اسرائيل او ان ان يعني يشكل خطر على
اسرائيل هذه تبدو يعني غريبه شوي مو قابله
للتصديق كما قلت ب مناح يقول
ذلهم مع الرو نعم المحلل السياسي من القدس
هو الذي يقول بانه ونتنياهو اصلا تحدث
بهذا المنطق وح ذر ايران ايضا من التواجد
على تلك الحدود من خلال حلفائها وبالتالي
هذا الامر اصبح يعني
معروفا يعني كما قلت لك يعني يبدو لي انه
يعني غير غير قابل للتصديق كما قلت كل هذه
القوات لا تستطيع ان تهزم مجموعاتها هذه
المعارضه السوريه ال التي نتحدث عنها في
القنيطره هي عباره عن مجموعات مشرد ولا
تملك لا طائرات ولا دروع ولا اي انوع من
انواع الاسلحه الثقيله ولا تستطيع ان
تهزمها فكيف لها ان تفكر بفتح جبهه مع
اسرائيل بالتاكيد الامر ليس ليس كذلك يعني
واسرائيل عندما ترسل هذه الرسائل كما قلت
هي ترسلها باتجاه مشروع ايراني كبير كامل
وربما تكون ايضا هناك احتمال وهذا حديث
يعني ظهر بالربيع الماضي انه اسرائيل تخطط
في خلال هذا الصيف يعني لايجاد ذريعه
لمهاجمه حزب الله في لبنان وبالتالي ضرب
المشروع الايران او مشروع الهيمنه
الايرانيه في مقتل ربما تكون هذه التحركات
لايجاد الذرا والظروف المناسبه لعمل من
هذا النوع قبل ان ان اخذ فاصل فقط بنقطه
رساله ضد مشروع ايراني معين ما هو المشروع
الايراني تحديدا في هضبه الجولان باختصار
سيد عبد
الناصر المشروع الايراني هو ايجاد ورقه
ضغط ما يعني ليست ورقه قوه بالمعنى الكبير
لكن ايجاد قواعد معينه يعني حرب عصابات
على حدود اسرائيل الشماليه للضغط عليها
لتقديم تنازلات في في بعض الملفات اللي
بتتعلق بالوجود الايراني والنفوذ الايراني
وغيره لكن ان تشكل خطر تهديد كبير على
اسرائيل وفي هذه الظروف التي يعاني منها
محور ايران من معارك يعني تمتد من اليمن
الى الى العراق الى سوريا لا اعتقد انهم
في هذا الوارد ولا يمكنهم ان يفكروا بهذا
الموضوع التضخيم الاسرائيلي لهذه المسائل
والرد وال الضجيج الاعلامي اعتقد انه ايضا
له هدف اخر وهو التلميح بانه ممكن يهيئوا
الاجواء لهجوم كبير قد يستهدف لبنان
بالدرجه الاولى وليس هضبه الجولان كما
يبدو الامر في ظاهره الانقى معي السيد عبد
الناصر العايد ويوني بن مناحيم مشاهدينا
بعد الفاصل نناقش المسارات المحتمله
للتصعيد في الجولان بين اسرائيل والنظام
السوري ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه
الحلقه التي تنا ناقش ابعاد ودلالات
التصعيد الاخير بين النظام السوري
واسرائيل في هضبه الجولان واعود الى يوني
بن مناحيم من القدس سيد بن
مناحيم قلت بان اسرائيل تريد ان يتحقق
الهدوء على في هضبه
الجولان كيف ترى ذلك اسرائيل هذا الهدوء
وهل صحيح انها تسعى الى اقامه شريط حدودي
بمحاذاه الجولان تماما كشريط الحدود الذي
كانت تقيمه في جنوب لبنان قبل عام
2000 ايه هذا الاحتمال هو وارد جدا واريد
ان اذكرك بان كان هناك كانت هناك حاله
هدوم من
67 لليوم اي واسرائيل تريد ان ان تحافظ
لهذا الهدوء كانت هذه سياسه الرئيس راحل
حفز الاسد وحتى سياسه بشار الاسد واسرائيل
تريد ان
تستمر سوريا في هذا الاتجاه بهذه السياسه
سياسه الهدوء ولكن اليوم تغيرت الظروف
وهناك درت ايراني واراده ايرانيه على
سوريا
اي وعلى فتح جبهه جديده في هدبه جولان
تعتمد لحرب العصابات
وتشكيل مقاومه شعب
في هدبه الجولان التي ستقول باعمال
تخريبيه ضد المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في هد
الجولان الشريط الحدو نعم الشريط الحدودي
الذي تقول نعم يمكن ان يكون من من الذي
سيسيطر عليه من وجهه نظر اسرائيل
طبعا هذه في
هناك مخططات لجيش الاسرائيلي وان لا اعلم
التفاصيل ولكن هذا احتمال هو وارد جدا اذا
فعلا اسرايل ستشعر بان نظام بشار الاسد لا
يريد الاستمرار
بسياسه الهدوء في هدبه الجولان في الطرف
السوري سيكون هناك ستكون هناك خطه
اسرائيليه
لانشاء حزام امني في هذه المنطقه كيف
السؤال المطروح كيف من خلال اجتياح في
هناك لا اعتقد ان اسرائيل ستدخل الى
السوريه وهي ستزال في في الحدود الحاليه
في هناك عده
مقترحات وفي هناك ايده
وسائل لخلق هذا الحزام الامني بدون دخول
الى الاراضي السوريه ما رايك في ذلك سيد
عبد الناصر
العايد يعني سمعنا بانه هناك خطه
اسرائيليه معده سلفا يعني التوغل بمسافه
16 م لفرض هذا
الحزام الامني او
الامن وبعتقد انه يعني ممكن يسووها
الاسرائيليين مش بعيده خاصه بانه يعني
الان ضيفك يعني اكد ما ما قلته في بدايه
الحلقه انه هذه الضربات هي هي صفعات
للنظام السوري للتنبه الى القيام بدوره
الوظيفي الذي كان يلعبه
بعهد حافظ الاسد وعهد وريثه من الحفاظ على
الهدوء على الجبهه الشماليه لاسرائيل
وايقاف التحركات الايرانيه التي تاتي في
اطار وجود مشروعين متنافسين للسيطره على
الرجل المريض المعاصر اللي هو العالم
العربي اي ضمن هذا الصراع يعني هناك
محاوله لمنع النظام السوري من الانجراف
كليا وراء المشروع الايراني هذا ما قاله
الان ضيفك تقريبا اذا لم اذا لم ينصاع
بالتاكيد سوف تقوم اسرائيل بحمايه يعني
مشروعها ومصالحها ومخططاتها الهيمنه بتدخل
مباشر سمعنا كما قلت انه هناك خطه ل 16 م
لكن ايضا سمعنا ومن مصادر يعني غربيه
تحديدا انه هناك خطه اخرى في حال انه
ايران ابدت مزيد من التمترس خلف مشروعها
ومحاوله الاندفاع به اكثر الى توجيه ضربه
قاسمه له في العمود الفقري لوجوده في
منطقه يعني بلاد الشام وهو لبنان وقلب
كافه الموازين وربما تك كون هذه التحركات
يعني والضربات الاسرائيل النوع من عمليه
استفزاز لاستدراج ضربات او ردود لحزب الله
او لمليشيات الايرانيه الاخرى لايجاد
ذريعه لحرب اكبر من هذا بكثير يعني قد لا
يتوقف الامر عن شقع استمرار يعني من خلال
ما افهمه منك تتوقع استمرار
لهذا التوتر وتصعيد هذا التوتر في
المستقبل اذا لم تتوسط روسيا لحل هذه
المشكله مع ايران بين يعني بين اسرائيل
وايران وروسيا سابقا تعهدت لا اسرائيل
بانه تراعي مصالحها بشكل كامل والطيران
الاسرائيلي قصف في قلب سوريا رغم كشفه من
الرادارات الروسيه ومرمى الصواريخ
والطيران الروسي لكن لم يتم اعتراضه اي
اذا لم تستطع روسيا اقناع يعني حليفها
الايراني ب تحجيم تحركاته في الجولان وا
الابتعاد عن هذه المنطقه اعتقد انه وقوع
يعني مواجهه اكبر بين ايران واسرائيل وارد
جدا شكرا لك عبد الناصر العايد الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من باريس
واشكر موصول الى يوني بن مناحي من
القدس نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر شكرا للمتابعه والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ن